two
welcome everybody
to area 51.
we have actually a corner office in area
51 i didn't want to say it that's right
we're working with the american
government to take down
all of the republican party that's right
the american government's a socialist
conspiracy alex jones was right
and they're working with us we're
working with china
we're working with the chinese communist
party to take down every republican
that's why that's why ethan klein didn't
get punished and not just elected
officials citizens too yeah yeah it's
all about war we can't even make jokes
about that anymore i think actually now
that we're coming for you well i mean
dude
with the brett kavanaugh uh thing that
happened which by the way don't make it
i want to talk about that and we'll talk
about it drink beer we drink beer
anyway uh listen
yes we are in an undisclosed location
underground 300 feet underground
with turrets anti-air impenetrable
nuclear we could sustain a nuclear head
nothing will ever reach us
so
yeah the the the south american
conference is happening right here in
this facility right now joe brandon is
here with us
we yeah he's like he's he's in the
waiting room yeah i asked him i asked
him to come on but he was like come on
jack i don't want to take the shot away
from you and ethan you boys are doing so
great cutting the malarkey he
he's waiting for the studio we said joe
just take a [ __ ] nap yeah yeah he's
yeah they brought him in
have some ice cream and ch and chill
economy
it does what's grown the economy joe
we're in terrible shape yeah things are
not looking too great
yeah well anyway today's episode is
sponsored by
doordashandstamps.com so love that shout
out to
those kings
um
son i i hate to do this but these always
happen on thursdays
are teddy fresh drops
i don't care
and uh
i'll be fast
you know teddyfresh.com new collection
just hit you see something you like
absent obvi i can't see anything right
now because i don't have my glasses are
you blind i am blind i don't have my
glasses i forgot to wear them because
last night i went out to the otk event
yeah and instead of going to sleep at 11
30 i went to sleep at like 12 30
basically yeah and that ruined
everything that's why i'm late that's
okay
and i forgot my minute three
that's insane yeah i mean i don't know
how you uh but you're a dad that's that
makes i get it is dad's style but man i
ca i was having weird dreams too man i
kept waking up it was a bad night
but okay well here i can zoom in for
your bedroom that's sick you want i
already i have like this a similar one
though i have the blue one this shirt is
really like brighter uh it's like a uh
jacquarded also i'll just put a package
together for you
but wait what's that is that a vest
it's it's uh is it for women yeah
sorry bro you wanna invest
one of time i think we were making a
vest coming up like and it's a dope what
about polo tea is that for women too
nope this is a men's shirt no the polo
tee up there to the left of the vest
this is a women's shirt yeah
i know that shirt's sick too man it's a
i wish i could this shirt is like super
nice i got the zip too it's a [ __ ]
card that's so i want that i don't care
what do they have like triple xl for
women i'll wear it on yeah but that
ain't gonna fit you bro no no those
women's sizes are not not that big for
guys like
for i'll i'll make it okay let's see
what happens it'll look funny
yeah give me the largest women's size
and i'll wear all of them and they know
you have it you uh getting those those
are sick too
dual colored shorts you want yeah
grab grab uh socks too are those also
for women tell me what it's not for
women ethan you show me this and you're
teasing you're like wait no this is
things this one's unisex these are
women's mad
yeah you want this one i already have
like a million hoodies oh
so we're not down with the you know okay
you want to know something actually
crazy this is unrelated but i i actually
i mean i i sell hoodies as well i hate
hoodies i'm a crewneck guy i'll come out
and say it
you want this crew here's a crew neck
my dad wears teddy fred i have that so
you have the box yeah all right we're
gonna have a lighter tone we're gonna
have to work on some new silhouettes for
you vests
and uh
is that a necklace i like that okay you
got that lina lock it up necklace there
you go
the casual shopping
shopping segment of the show well you
know we like to enjoy ourselves anyway
um teddyfresh.com you want to plug your
[ __ ] hassan well i have nothing i mean i
have a i have a new line coming out for
ideology soon but it's not you know what
i'm still working on okay let us know
we'll give it a nice juicing plug here
on the line
speaking of plugs
i was on bbc world i know i have a clip
of it should i pull it up
yeah i mean you can you pull up a clip
if you want so so how did this come
together um i think one of the dudes
that's a producer is a fan because he
not only reached out to my manager but
he also reached out to my mods so when
someone reaches out to my moderators
it's probably it's actually a cheat code
it's the easiest way to like it's the
quickest and shortest way to access me
um
is either like writing in the chat when
i'm live because i will read it and then
i'll yell at you or reaching out to one
of my moderators right
um and he did both so i was like all
right normally i don't do this like a
lot of media out ask me to do slots like
this all the time but i refuse to do it
because i'm always live on twitch and
i'm streaming
so i was like [ __ ] it i'll do it as long
as i can do it while i'm you know
co-streaming on twitch and that's crazy
they were fine with it so like you know
they got to see the background the the
production side a little bit like my
audience did so this was on uh cable
television oh yeah it was uh yeah it is
on [ __ ] he was on the telly
here it is hassan was on a bbc world
wearing by the way wearing a teddy fresh
shirt
and showcasing sam's original art yeah
and
and uh of course the queen was
prominently behind me as well yeah it's
the platinum jubilee
[ __ ] jubilee can you have a jubilee
when you're 90. there's nothing jubilee
about i don't even know what that means
i have no idea what the [ __ ] platinum
jubilee means i don't know what it is
like a party right it's like a
celebration the platy jew brav
that's what it is
anyway let's check it out what did
hassan say on the bbc people want in
america and what the politicians are
going to end up doing are two very
different things
for
the past i would say decade if not
longer there has been almost a uh
complete consensus on expanding
background checks in this country to
universal background checks and closing
up certain loopholes like the gun show
loophole or private sales
that pulls around 90 percent i think my
latest measures is around like 85
percent if i'm not mistaken and yet this
is not even a is a non-starter by uh the
republican party they don't even
consider it to be a conversation what
the people want in america and what the
politicians are going to end up doing
are two variables
different things
wow
laying it down on the bbc
our very own they were not positive like
they were like well it seems like mitch
mcconnell was even making concessions i
was like no that's just that's
hell no bro [ __ ] that old crusty [ __ ]
ass kfc looking [ __ ] yeah and by the way
he's very he's shaking in his boots
right now because of the brett kavanaugh
stuff he was like we need to uh i was
gonna say i mean [ __ ] you i'm gonna puke
bro [ __ ] they go [ __ ] you
that's george peterson we'll get to that
but they're crying in the [ __ ] senate
about how you better pass this bill by
night's fault
because what happened someone with the
gun was out
no i can't i'm just so
no yes mr mcconnell's a little bit more
like
yeah you got to get the neck [ __ ] here
it's like
the nessie like you got it yeah he has a
fat nussy like i i don't know you could
like any [ __ ] is it it's like it's like
a shriveled goiter like he had like a
fat goiter that like
sucked it back in and now it's just all
skin
i don't like to call people ugly because
it's like well what does that even mean
you know what like he's disgusting he's
a raisin [ __ ] freak bro he looks like
the turtleman that darn that dana carvey
played i think i think beauty comes from
both like external features certainly
but all more importantly your internal
features and i think like a lot of
republicans are so horrifically
disfigured as a consequence of just like
what is happening inside of them that's
interesting so i i do think that like i
don't have a problem like you know
saying marjorie taylor green looks like
a [ __ ] titan from attackers he does
though that's not even like to call her
who's gonna get mad you know how like
people always say like look at this man
you calling mitch mcconnell is not gonna
hurt his feelings but someone that looks
like mitch mcconnell will be hurt it's
like no one looks like him no i agree
by the way you wanna know how are you a
turtle bro literally do you wanna know
how good my comparison was here's turtle
yeah dana carvey it's young yeah he
actually looks much better i'll be
honest yeah that's like mitch mcconnell
after he gets a bbl and then also gets
like the skin graft and all that
you know but he got he was like all
right here let me do my best looking
sexy he goes
someone was with a gun outside of uh uh
brett ryan brett kavanaugh's house you
almost called him ryan
[ __ ] those dead kids
oh
19 kids died [ __ ] them we need more
security for our little golden goose boy
our good boy brett kavanaugh
who just made who just made it so border
control officers can [ __ ]
do anything they want to you
yeah by the way
that's that's a perfect is exactly what
i how i felt like 19 kids dead not going
to make any changes to any sort of like
meaningful legislation
uh you know
some guy
maybe he just was an american citizen
demonstrating his right to own a bunch
of cool things what you guys want yeah
this is the second amendment in action
yeah
uh so what actually happened though
someone was just cruising outside his
house no no no he's from simi valley
california and he's a lib i think yeah
i'm pretty sure he was like very pissed
off about the abortion decision he was
very he was worried that like you know
gun uh laws were about to get even less
restricted which is wild like how much
what are they gonna like forcibly give
every baby in ar15 like like the guy who
went to his house was like
pro gun
no no no i i don't think he's pro guns i
think he was anti-guns there is a little
bit of confusion there though in the way
that they covered it but i read the new
york times article but he was he was mad
about the abortion thing and he wanted
to make his life have meaning
and he was of course he was also
mentally ill
um and
he
he went to brett kavanaugh's house with
like a you know dressed in all black he
had a suitcase black suitcase with them
uh that had um beer that that basically
you know definitely a beer he he had a
black suitcase with him that had uh you
know a weapon like a pistol
knives i think like a crowbar like some
crazy he was like [ __ ] kidding it'll
work yeah zip ties you know whoa the
standard the the standard january 16th
starter kit it's the january 6 tour pack
yeah exactly exactly
yeah having some beers with friends
so so he did that he had all that but
then he chickened out last second and
like called uh the authorities and was
like i'm suicidal and i'm gonna kill
brett kavanaugh like come arrest me
please reported yeah he's self-reported
interesting so there's no guys um so
yeah um so that's what happened don't
they already have security
the justices uh i don't
i
don't think so i think that right now
there's like private security probably i
thought they had like uh wow no no
justices are on insecure they're they
have no security supreme court justices
have no security they do not get uh
secret service protection
are you
putting something out there no of course
not i would never do that i'm just
letting you know that they are not they
are soft targets they are soft targets
no but that's actually a good point like
they are literally soft targets
and you know we talk about like how
schools are soft targets or whatever but
like
all of those [ __ ] schools have
incompetent ass like uh you know hot dog
skinned potato bag looking uh police
officers that are sitting around
twiddling their [ __ ] thumbs eating
donuts and like harassing black and
brown children at school and not really
doing anything when the moment like the
moment that they're actually supposed to
spring to action but these guys are
gonna get the best [ __ ] security so
they're fine because they're actually in
a position of power you and your you
know uh children that go to elementary
school though [ __ ] those kids you know
what i mean like the american government
could not give a [ __ ]
well it doesn't i mean you can't put
seal team six at every [ __ ] school
the whole premise is absurd in my
opinion yeah
we should stop even doing these dumb
[ __ ] drills that just traumatize kids
active shooter drills are literally just
traumatic and they don't help and i
don't even think we need police officers
on campus because
basically all you're doing is turning
schools into prisons where
[ __ ] the first of all police are bad
enough to have around you really want
them
like basically i've been reading a lot
about this when there's police officers
on campus
there's just more arrests there's more
trouble
there it's it's actually so
counterproductive it's [ __ ] insane
and they never stop shooting i mean case
in point yeah they literally do not stop
shooting all they do is just arrest kids
for [ __ ] and and here's the thing
here's the concession for me okay uh mr
mr acap okay
oh
i i mean
it's understandable that they can't stop
[ __ ] mass shootings like they're
human beings okay it is very difficult
the military which is a different set of
rules of engagement and even then has
like a [ __ ] load more training with
combat and weapons
still have a hard time uh stopping you
know shootings and whatnot swat teams
have a hard time stopping shootings
because there's still cops like this is
a normal thing it's normal for them to
not be able to like become john rambo in
the way that they claim that they're
supposed to be
so what do you have to do offer systemic
solutions like making it harder to get
guns wait a little bit longer to get a
gun you know what i mean like these guys
know exactly what that's like these guys
know exactly what that's like when it
comes to deterrence for abortions you
know you have to travel to like the one
abortion facility in your [ __ ] state
and wait 72 hours after a doctor legally
lies to you but you can't do any kind of
restriction for for you know guns it's
so stupid abortions are something you
can do on your own body it's about
bodily autonomy guns are just like
purchasing a commodity
incredible bro i don't know i feel like
very defeatist i feel very black-pilled
lately
yeah i don't even know like this whole
thing is just so upsetting you know like
we're not even talking about taking
people's guns away for [ __ ] sake i i
think just raise the age to 21 would
caught would would fix a lot of the
issues because these mass shooters are
[ __ ] 18 19 20.
raise the age a universal background
track i mean what kind of psychotic
[ __ ] freak is against that
red flags what the [ __ ] is more
complicated than that because like uh
like i said you have if you have nothing
if you're living a life of despair if
you're living a life of of isolation if
you feel alienated from your labor if
you feel social alienation and the only
thing that like brings a sense of
community to you is you know your your
commodity fetishization your purchases
i.e a gun or a funko pop or the marvel
cinematic universe but in this
circumstance a gun
um you're very effectively and and
there's a there's a gun manufacturing
industry that makes billions of dollars
and has created this uh think tank or
sorry this lobbying organization that is
effectively mobilizing that one interest
that you have
you become a force to be reckoned with
politically speaking taking away the
[ __ ] your guns i know but it doesn't
matter because they've put the fear of
god into people i know yeah the obvious
45 percent of americans think that jesus
christ is going to come back in the next
50 years and like the rapture is going
to [ __ ] happen right 42 it's like a
psychotic number uh you know wow
it's an insane percentage i always say
on my show you know you can get 30 of
americans to believe like you can get 30
of americans to say they agree with
anything like literally anything
i don't know i feel very blackville you
know it's like
especially seeing how the republicans
are just like you need to get more
security for brett kavanaugh it's like
[ __ ]
you
tell brett kavanaugh to buy a gun arm
his kids and and close off all the doors
yeah what's up yeah it's the same
security that the kids do yeah why
shouldn't yeah why why is brett
kavanaugh and like the supreme court
justice getting an additional layer of
protection dude just when all it takes
is a [ __ ] yeah doesn't he have a 50
cal dude yeah use that arm yourself bro
it's not that big it's not that
complicated
four out of ten republican sticks mass
shootings are unfortunately something
you have to accept as part of a free
society just to emphasize the point
hassan just made about you can get
people to agree to almost anything well
that's what they're saying
that's what they're saying and i mean
how do you contend with
such brazen bad
faith
pathetic like
just so [ __ ] insultingly stupid
one door [ __ ] ted cruz
one door we need to reduce the amount of
doors i mean how do you contend with
that it's not even a real argument and
everybody [ __ ] knows it it's just
it i just feel so black-pilled i've
moved
talking about uh how republicans are
[ __ ] demons and how republican voters
are [ __ ] stupid and all this stuff
because i think everyone is stupid
that's why i always talk about like the
despair
people just don't have anything in their
lives all they have are toys so when the
government that's not giving you
anything that you [ __ ] hate that you
feel like is only stealing your money in
the form of taxes that uh is not even
fixing the [ __ ] potholes in your
neighborhood uh right uh
is is then turning around and saying
like well we're gonna make it harder for
you to get your toys
uh and you have been trained conditioned
into mobilizing on behalf of like
advocacy for said toys you're gonna go
[ __ ] buck wild
i get it i just don't know what's going
to give i feel like everything is just a
charade i just feel so block-billed bro
i don't know
yeah
you know
learning you and you learn about like
these [ __ ] kids they are so mutilated
and [ __ ] up a couple of them were
decapitated their bodies were absolutely
eviscerated okay yeah that's what that's
a five five six that's what that does
it's like specifically designed to be
what eight times faster significantly
more gunpowder loaded into it it's
supposed to explode inside of your body
that's what it's designed for because
it's designed for murdering human beings
um that's why whenever you hear you know
like john thune come out and be like
it's for varmints i'm shooting prairie
dogs it's like you're not you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] the only reason why you're
defending the ar-15 is because it's
[ __ ] cool looking okay and because
the gun lobby and the gun manufacturers
sell a [ __ ] load of it because you can
customize it the gun manufacturers make
a lot of money from selling it because
the most popular rifle and more
importantly the gun stores make a
shitload of money off the [ __ ]
customizing options that you can put on
the ar-15 that still like i said looks
sexy okay it's just fun to shoot it's
easy to shoot but it's designed not for
hunting you can't hunt with it that
would be [ __ ] ridiculous if you
brought it destroy your
game you can't use it for home defense
because you're not gonna blow past like
three of your [ __ ] walls and possibly
shoot your goddamn neighbor okay
um
you're simply you're simply using it
because it's cool and fun to shoot
that's it and i say this as someone who
shoots a lot of ar-15s i've shot ghost
guns like that have no serial number
i've shot uh ar-15s with serial numbers
i've shot pistol grip ar-15s are you
shooting
grips uh i i have uh i know someone who
made one in new mexico legally oh
interesting yeah like a 3d printed thing
no it's uh those lower 80 things we were
talking about the other day on the show
as long as you can drill a hole into a
lower uh into a lower like
they claim that blacksmithing or
gunsmithing is constitutionally
protected by the second amendment as
well and that you can just uh
you can just as long as you drill your
own [ __ ] uh lower you can finish it
and and complete it it doesn't have a
serial number because like the gun is
technically considered the lower part
and that's what that's what is
serialized
so um
you can just literally buy like legos or
an ikea table all the other pieces from
the internet and very quickly put it
together
i did it once with a friend of mine who
bought one
took like
an hour and a half in the afternoon
built a gun well who cares about
registration numbers that seems
unconstitutional too i mean they do make
that argument yeah why do we need that
so that is a really good question uh i i
think that uh we need to get rid of
those no we should definitely have
registration and it should at the very
least as a starting point resemble the
dmv and like the similar structure to
cars
so um the fact that we don't have that
is completely psychotic bananas by the
year 2050 a 41 of americans believe that
jesus christ definitely
or probably will have returned
to earth
hallelujah told you
yeah nothing's gonna happen though and
i'm realizing that
and it's just makes me [ __ ] sick to
my stomach man and if you can't like
just it really just says how doomed we
are if you can't even change
some really common sense
things like again we're not even talking
about outright banning rifles or
anything like that really basic common
sense stuff
uh in the wake of such a horrific
tragedy then like what can we do it's on
us um here i i'm usually the
person and just one more thing
you know i go well we gotta vote we
gotta turn out i mean the la election
just took place it had horrible turnout
and rick caruso
a [ __ ] uh wolf in sheep's clothes
billionaire
it got more votes i don't know if he's
going to win but he got more votes
because california liberals the rich
that do end up voting the older people
that do end up voting especially in the
primaries are the type of people that
are straight up like yeah i'm a lifelong
democrat lifelong liberal also i think
we should melt homeless people for bio
matter yes um so they are really
reactionary they get whipped up into a
frenzy by local news and like there's a
california crime wave [ __ ] that's
been going on for a very long time which
i've addressed numerous times uh is a
falsehood uh mass hysteria campaign by
the police
and the media that works in unison with
them but here and as pessimistic as i am
normally i think that there is
there are good things happening and i've
talked about this a bunch of times on um
on my broadcast as well like look the
only thing you can do is organize okay
uh voting alone is not going to is not
going to do anything it's not going to
cut it because if you're ultimately
voting for the feckless democratic party
that's not doing anything and you have
no mechanism to enforce your will upon
the democratic party then you have
nothing right you're just voting to make
yourself feel good for a brief moment
make yourself feel like you're team one
and then the democrats sit around throw
their hands up in the air and go we
can't do anything because the
republicans are far too powerful even
when they're in a position of power like
we are currently right so what do you do
well you need an enforcement mechanism
and the only way to do that historically
speaking has been aside from violence
obviously is to
push the democratic party through labor
unions uh organizing your workplace will
immediately offer you a
a good feeling and more autonomy over
the political process that takes place
in your workplace and then on top of
that
you will join a legion of working-class
people in this country that can unite
together and have more power than than
you ever thought you could you could
bully the democratic party into
submission you could bully the
democratic party to act out your desires
because clearly
saying that you're just not going to
vote for the democratic party doesn't
really matter
in a country where the plurality in most
elections doesn't even [ __ ] vote they
know that already they know that like
most people don't vote and they don't
care they're relying on
um you know they're relying on the the
little amount of people that do end up
going out to vote that are fearful of
the republican party to spring to action
and put them in back into positions of
power the democrats i mean
i'm blocked bro
no reason there's look i'm i'm usually
the most black bill person i'm telling
you like there are good things happening
starbucks unionizing is happening all
across the country you've got the amazon
labor union shut up the chris malls like
there are efforts happening all around
the country uh labor power is the only
way out of this uh and then also you
know organizing just like one starbucks
store that unionized
no no no it's not one starbucks so so
what union did they join
or did they they have their own and what
is it called uh the starbucks union
so so can everyone in every store across
the country join it now yeah as long as
they vote uh democratically as long as
they vote to join a union they can join
it yeah they just crossed a hundred
stores nationally yeah oh no starbucks
is [ __ ] and pissing right now yeah
notice how you don't [ __ ] hear that
though in the news like the reason why
you don't hear about that a lot is it is
very suspicious that like
a lot of uh news media is not covering
that at all
strange so so why would a specific store
because i know there's probably tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of starbucks across the country
why is it that stores wouldn't join that
um why would people not want to join a
union yeah um ant union propaganda
people still have i mean it ties along
with red scare propaganda you need to be
very powerful some of the unions were
also kind of corrupt okay let's be real
you know maybe some mob connections uh
some of the unions were also a little
racist okay uh but currently that's not
the case obviously the actual
unionization rate of the black labor
force is significantly higher than the
white labor force as a matter of fact um
so you know [ __ ] anyone that lies to you
about that but uh there is a lot there's
a multi-billion dollar industry of
lawyers and and you know anti-union uh
you know labor lawyers that come into
your office and give
these coercive
um captive audience meetings
under the guise of like what could
happen potentially if you unionize they
tell you you're a family at the
workplace that your workplace actually
cares about you and the union is
outsiders even though the union is
literally comprised of you the workers
so um there is just so much uh there's
so much money and so
uh so many very successful efforts at
the
uh at the at the judicial level at the
legislative level that has completely
crippled the union power their their
organizational capacity and uh
oftentimes you know even the nlrb which
is like uh pretty gutted uh will will be
forced to not be able to take a look at
exactly what's going on in
companies that are routinely violating
the previous laws that were set in place
for unionization to occur in the
workplaces i mean that's like not to
blackpill you further but capital is
very popular or not popular but rather
they're very successful at destroying
any sort of labor momentum historically
in this country
and are peop and our starbucks union
people making more money at this point
or not yet well right now uh they're
just unionizing um eventually they'll be
able to engage in collective bargaining
yeah and then
they will be able to because
and are you willing to pay five cents
more for your coffee though yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] exactly that was what papa
john did remember that he's like listen
i'd love to give all my employees
insurance but you all can be paying 10
cents more for our pizza can you really
handle that yeah and except like that's
also [ __ ] because
by the way papa john i love you remember
these guys have not actually done uh
these guys have not even unionized and
yet prices are [ __ ] skyrocketing
what's up let's go branded right you
know what i mean inflation inflation is
not uh specifically because like you
know uh workers are able to
have more control over their workplaces
okay that's it's been happening despite
the declining rate of unionization in
this [ __ ] country over the past
[ __ ] what you know
60 years
i love pizza and i love people
just as long as it needs to possibly ten
more cents to insure them
um let's move on to something more fun
okay
all right let's deal with all this [ __ ]
seriously depressing
actually we are
no exactly at 30 minutes are we really
yeah we could do our break and then
we'll do something fun right now so
before if don't stay tuned because the
next jordan peterson video i want to
watch is [ __ ]
incredible
it's so good
so let's thank our sponsors real fast
okay
first of all
a big old [ __ ] juicy thank you to
doordash who is almost solely
responsible for me being
so [ __ ] fat
and i need that as a compliment i don't
know if that's positive well it is what
it is right it is what it is you could
doordash healthier options
sure you can i i you could i use
delivery services all the time as well
pretty much every day and um i i
order from chipotle
yeah chipotle
or rotisserie chicken place how much can
you eat chipotle i mean really that [ __ ]
is
soul crushing after like three times
unfortunately it's very hit or miss if
it was it if it wasn't like if chipotle
had like consistency i would eat it two
meals a day it's when it misses man it's
so [ __ ] it's like wet because i eat i
eat a bowl like i don't eat burrito i
don't eat like a burrito so like the the
the likelihood of it missing is way
higher
sometimes it's like tell me what do you
put in your bowl
uh double steak steak is 150 calories
less than the chicken that they use uh
double steak uh brown rice black beans
fajitas
all the all the salsas with the
exception of the corn one that one's
[ __ ] oh i agree no corn i don't use
the corn one because it's 80 calories uh
and then cheese that's not why i don't
and lettuce and sometimes if i'm feeling
myself i get a little side of guac too
oh yeah you don't [ __ ] with the sour
cream
well i mean it's calories i'm like i'm
trying to balance it like a high protein
a little bit of carbs a little bit a
little bit of fat you know what i mean
so that's that's what i get and then i
eat that with the quest chips how much
do you weigh
right now i'm like 2
59 hopefully you know what's crazy as
[ __ ] what and also blackpilling me right
now is that we weigh similar amounts
i mean yeah let's go but you're like
you're like a
towering [ __ ] monster what's your i
muscle mass and that's the difference
we can make that happen for you yeah and
i've been we weigh the same amount bro
i've been talking i've been talking
about like we're gonna put you on
steroids
yeah i know you guys want me to fight um
i saw that clip of you guys talking
about me yeah you guys want me to fight
keemstar we just want you
just sterilize no exercising [ __ ] it
straight to the strokes with that all
right when you do it when you take this
areas you probably want to do it you'll
probably want to so if i get on steroids
will i get jacked even without
exercising no yeah no you'll my penis
will just shrink for no reason your
penis doesn't shrink on steroids is it
your balls are the balls yeah your balls
shrink potentially let's go
i'm such a i'm such an advocate for
steroids even though i don't take them
i'm too much of a coward i'm too into a
coward to take it myself because i'm
like an addict you don't need that [ __ ]
dude you're already jacked why do you
need steroids i just don't get it
your balls are gonna be little skittles
dude it'll make my dick look bigger
you think so by shrinking your balls i
know dan i know i know we'll get there
we'll get we'll get to
oh we're doing the sponsor we'll get the
door down
doordash
[Laughter]
dude you i don't think you want your
balls to shrink can't get can't get
steroids on doordash that's illegal
that's a different delivery service yeah
all right listen up guys have you got
back-to-back meetings errands to run or
chores to take care of what's the secret
to cleaning your to-do list a little
help from doordash you can get dinner
household essentials and everything on
your grocery list delivered
gabish
get what you want to eat right now and
right to your door along with
restaurants you love you can now get
groceries and other essential items
delivered with doordash get drinks
snacks and other household items in
under an hour
are you craving late night ice cream
have you forgotten that one key
ingredient for dinner
or maybe you just need to stock up for
the week with doordash get everything in
one app with 300 000 partners you can
support your neighborhood go to or
choose from favorite national chains
like popeye's chipotle and cheesecake
factory
ordering is easy
and your item will be left safely
outside your door when you choose
contact contact list delivery drop-off
thank god for that i love that contact
let's
drop off but here
check this out guys this is big for a
limited time our offer our listeners can
get 25 off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of fifteen dollars or
more
let me say that again
when you download the doordash app and
enter the code leftovers i'm talking
about free money on your next
food order that's 25 off up to 10 bucks
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
and enter the code leftovers don't
forget that's code leftovers for 25 off
your first order with doordash
subject to change terms applied thank
you doordash
thank you thank you and finally stamps
we love stamps don't we folks i love the
different kinds of uh you know guitar
riffs you got going on for each of the
ads it's you know you gotta buy it yeah
yeah i love stamps
nothing more american than stamps that's
true the postal service is older than
the united states of america there you
have it
don't [ __ ] with the postal service
listen guys i personally love stamps man
this is such a great service uh if
you're running a small business every
second counts and you can't afford to
waste a single second so why are you
wasting time going to the [ __ ] post
office when you could be using
stamps.com instead you don't have to
think about it that's right stamps.com
makes mailing and shipping quick easy
and cost effective
um
check this out guys with stamps.com
you get discounts you can't find
anywhere else thirty percent off usps
rates
86 off ups
ridiculous all you need
to get started with stamps.com
is their easy to use software
regular computer printer no special
supplies or equipment you're up and
running in minutes printing official
postage for any letter any package
anywhere you want to send it
it works seamlessly with shopify amazon
etsy ebay more
and you know if you're just sending
invoices or you're sending products or
you got a whole dang warehouse of stuff
stamps.com is your best friend
um
and of course they've got a great great
offer for you
sign up with our promo code leftovers
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale
no long-term commitment and contracts
that scale by the way you use it to
weigh the package it prints it up you
know how much it costs you don't have to
go anywhere you just leave it on your
doorstep they come and pick it up or you
put it in the mailbox that's crazy you
don't have to think about it magic
it is it's not magic at stamps.com damn
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code leftovers thank you to our
wonderful
sponsors today
we love them
yes sir
all right let's get to this jordan
peterson cringe
because at least something makes me
happy i personally did not watch this on
purpose because i wanted this to be a
fresh reaction it's so [ __ ] good okay
he's so off the rails it's nuts
yes i love him okay here we go he's an
intellectual giant i don't know what you
guys are talking about yeah just [ __ ]
jealous like you're right the the
supremely confident intellectual big
brain genius of our era alpha yes the
alpha is like you know talking about who
he cannot wank to like this is what is
this is what is intellectual
conversation talking
yeah to his daughter he's been talking
about this issue for
like a month now he came over that
someone who was like
like a little bit overweight yeah he
went from like what will we do without
men to what will we do without
sexy ladies i want to jerk off
fat chicks are ruining america yeah
michaela don't let me catch you catching
any putting any weight up yeah i'll
[ __ ] disown you
yeah if i don't want to [ __ ] my own
daughter michaela i mean she is looking
good she looks okay she looks like she
eats only meat yeah i'm not into that
that's a turn off yeah me too i hate
that you want you would do it bro she
eats only i had raw liver the other day
you did how was it yeah it was actually
surprisingly not bad i hate liver like
liver is a part of turkish cuisine like
you know we eat normal like not raw
liver yeah but this homie was uh he made
it like he marinated like a like a poke
bowl and it actually was kind of fire
like great man you're on your way to
becoming an
ancestor i do love bone marrow as well i
had that last week too so well bone
marrow bone marrow raw or cooked though
no i don't know of course cooked
i mean look i'm not eating like like
pieces of [ __ ] fat inside the bone
like that's terrible liver king does
because he's disgusting he's a psycho
but bone marrow is just like fat it's
also good he went on the logan paul
podcast and he did not come on this one
which is kind of bro i'm like [ __ ] this
guy we reached out to him a long ass
time ago even before logan and they said
that's what i'm saying bro i don't know
what to think about and we said liver
king come on we're huge fans they say
we're not doing press right now
okay we're liver peasants dog come on
yeah he was on tour for his
movie or something what was it a movie
what was it that he said you know i
don't know yeah he said he had a movie
or something and then he don't have no
[ __ ] movie
but anyway he said no no sorry no press
and then he shows up on logan paul's
podcast
raw liver yeah
anyway let's watch jordan peterson
you think that would you not be turned
off by by a girl who just eats only meat
bro raw does she even cook it or is it
raw
i mean i'd like to i'd like there is
partner that eats a little bit of
something else i feel like i feel like
and this goes for dudes too like i'll
just start off by saying dudes the dudes
version of this first like there's no
way
if i only ate meat my semen is not
tasting good okay there's no [ __ ]
shot and i think the same goes for for
whoever is only eating a like a meat
diet meat only diet on the women's side
too because like the vagina is like a
very delicate but self-cleaning you know
thing so
the ph levels got to be all kinds of
[ __ ] up down there you know what i
mean you're sweating out like oil from
every orifice at a certain point and i
think that's probably nasty so but also
i'm into it michaela um
you you want to get down i'm just
kidding
so wait so so you're conscious about how
your teammate your semen taste so what
are we doing about that no i'm i'm just
saying that it would probably not taste
good because i i feel like it's just
you're unhealthy you know what i mean
shit's probably toxic cinnamon tastes
good
um av where did you send that message i
don't see it on the podcast yet a
leftovers chat uh reportedly she cooks
her meat by she fries it or roasts it
adds salt and washes it down with
sparkling water is that her official
that is so nasty dude that's the [ __ ]
um she got that tip from the cobra tape
yeah she got that the thing is
got the tip all right
sorry i
i love meat like i eat meat every day i
eat a lot of chicken uh i eat a lot of
you know i eat all kinds of meat i'm a
fan okay
that is [ __ ] insane that's just not
good for you that's insane it's
unhealthy don't understand how people
still go along with that insane diet
yeah i mean of course you're losing
weight you're just eating meat like
you're not getting anywhere close to
what your body needs nutritionally well
yeah because protein is super dense and
how you will fill you up there's no way
you're gonna get your caloric needs just
eating meat that's just [ __ ] crazy
oh here she is here she is
uh eating a couple of
whatever the [ __ ] those i mean at least
she cooks it this is not raw you know
what i'm saying that don't look too bad
dude how do you just eat that though
that doesn't look too bad i can't do it
your heart has got to be failing i'm
saying yeah it looks good but i'm just
saying if you're eating only red meat
that is [ __ ] that's like a butter yeah
you gotta have like crazy cholesterol
right i mean gotta be so fatty at a
certain point that you're just
exclusively consuming animal fat and
animal protein so bad now especially cow
is which is bad i'm the meat chef but
i'm someone asked liver king maybe it
was logan paul do you check your
cholesterol yeah he's like i don't
believe in that [ __ ]
i don't believe in cholesterol primals
that's all [ __ ] liver king's gonna
die in like two years yeah
his heart is gonna explode he's so
incredibly red which i don't think it's
just from the sun like there's no shot
that's just from the sun
uh you know i think that's like a
vitamin deficiency or something i don't
know what's going on but he's just like
bright red dude how do they not all have
like scurvy and [ __ ] like you can't just
eat meat only right yeah well he might
well you know as long as apparently as
long as they don't have apple cider
they're good you know
you have a little bit of apple cider
you're [ __ ] dead son
liver kig forces his kids to go on his
diet too which is pretty wild child
abuse straight up
son i've made you need to eat this raw
ground beef there today no [ __ ] no
fruit i just want to know son put that
apple down you [ __ ] coward bro he
would look so funny if you shaved his
beard because like it would be so white
from many many years of never seeing the
sun
i i bet he has a weak jaw too he's doing
a speed run he's like am is my heart
going to explode or am i going to die of
cancer speed rune maybe this is why
liver didn't come on
well we were you guys were very
complimentary i'm still complimentary
look i'm a sim i'm a simple man okay
when i see a body like that i still
respect it no matter what else is going
on i could [ __ ] liver king bro
[Laughter]
yeah i would love that uh
the the point is like that that requires
a tremendous amount of dedication and i
still respect that regardless of the
story yeah so does [ __ ] beating elgin
ring on new game plus seven and you
don't see me flexing all the time
you actually did flex about that a lot
no you one yeah you do flex non-stop
about that and two not all i talk about
it's very unhealthy for you whereas like
this oh really that's unhealthy
man is on the verge of death
let's be real i don't know i mean that
at that body fat percentage like he's
definitely not doing all right for sure
like i have like the lowest he's
literally my body fat percentage got the
lower my sex drive was back in the day
you know it just like did not make me
feel good at all i felt like [ __ ] all
the time but
you're still closer to a healthy
lifestyle by just gaining a little bit
of fat you know the question is do you
think he has a hog in his pants um he's
got tiny little nuts i know that
because he's all i don't i don't think
he has a fat hog i don't like he he's
too much of a bodybuilder
even if it is like over average it's
gonna look small because his muscles are
so big you know
i don't know if that's how that works he
has lower body fat percentage lower your
body fat percentage is the the more
the more the more penis you show
oh you think oh so that is that why you
want to get so lower low body fat no i
want to get a little body fat so i can
take my shirt off and take photos take
sexy ass liver king style photos
all right you know i've been i've been
showing some nipple on my instagram
lately
all right let's watch this damn all
right clip
[ __ ] you
tweet it though sorry not beautiful and
then everyone's sorry i already got a
positive sorry not sorry
tweeted out sorry not beautiful sorry
everyone got upset yes they did they had
a rather overweight young woman with a
very revealing swimsuit on the cover and
i thought it was not okay sorry shut the
[ __ ] up jordan it was like not it was
fairly modest it was a normal zone that
[ __ ] was not even covering her
disgusting body it made me spit
it's just show that pull up that picture
it's like [ __ ] tame it's a normal
it's a normal swimsuit i don't know why
jordan peterson become isis
yeah i i that's the [ __ ] i mean of
course he's also apparently talking to a
lot of like muslim content creators
jordan peterson is huge in the islam
world by the way for those of you who
don't know oh my god oh 1 million
yes i got turkish homies being like in
my hometown we have the highest muslim
population in the u.s they all love
jordan peterson yeah what do they love
about him they're just the truth because
he's a [ __ ] fundamentalist he's like
he's like a he's the perfect person
because he is a you know he's a
christian wahhabist like
he he literally will
um he he's liberal enough to not be like
super offensive you know what i mean
he's canadian it's like impossible for
him to be like super offensive and the
american muslim population is also very
progressive and very liberal in many
ways right like they are they're way
more liberal than the white evangelical
protestants
so i think he comes across as like
appealing while still simultaneously
seeing the world from uh like you know a
a religious perspective so he gives them
the tools to to feel better about like
practicing well while still holding on
to a thin veneer of progressivism this
is what
um he describes as a scantily clad
bikini they had a rather overweight
young woman with a very revealing
swimsuit on the cover and i thought no
the cover bothered me a lot because it
was a cheap manipulation of something
that had been working very well for
sports illustrated it was also an
insistence that all of a sudden this
non-athletic body is as beautiful as the
standard swimsuit model it's not it's
not as athletic and it's not as healthy
and that's that and then it's a lie
that's a manipulation of that young kid
they're not on her side they're
exploiting her and she may be positive
in that exploitation but they're still
exploiting she he's like he's like a
little kid
like
aren't you getting that energy from him
being like i no and that's that i could
not find it attractive and that made me
very usually usually i'm able to bust in
a couple minutes when my new sports
illustrated arrives
but i couldn't i couldn't come yeah he's
like i was it ruined my whole week
michaela
beautiful
sorry not beautiful
but his whole thing is weird like dude
it's just one cover bro they're not
trying to [ __ ] make you attracted to
also like they're trying to be
representative of women sports
illustrated like you know 11 months of
the year is showing you all the [ __ ]
unrealistic beauty standards that are
impossible to achieve without steroids
and like hundreds of thousands of
dollars that you dump into like a having
a food specialist control every facet of
your diet and then also on top of that a
[ __ ] load of photoshop and like he's not
crying about that like you could bust
the nut for 11 months dog it's fine like
the one month or they're like we're
gonna do the swimsuit issue and it's
gonna reflect the reality of women on
the ground just for one cover bro chill
the [ __ ] out dude and and again like as
we found out
the internet likes fake women more than
they like jordan peterson so yeah
you know i think what happened was it be
i don't he didn't break the story became
this culture war issue amongst con his
conservative cohorts and he saw it as a
thing he could jump on and i think he
took it too [ __ ] far and a lot of
people were like dude yeah dude like my
girlfriend looks like chill bro what the
[ __ ]
yeah a lot of his fans but anyway here
athletic body is as beautiful as the
standard swimsuit model it's not it's
not as athletic and it's not as healthy
and that's that and then it's a lie
that's a manipulation of that young
woman they're not on her side they're
exploiting her and she may be
participating in that exploitation this
is like a whole little extra layer he's
trying to put on there to uh justify
being so it's so like paternalistic
where you're like oh i'm saving you from
what a tremendous amount of financial
success and admiration
they don't care about you
thanks yeah why because like they said
you're beautiful just the way you are
wow that's so exploitative i hate that
parents you are oh god oh no oh no
this is male 1 yes yes yes
oh god oh god
they should put me up there with my
daughter
both of us naked bodies glistening in
the sun a dilf wait that picture
literally exists
i just realized oh yeah that is the
cover of her book or whatever oh my god
the cover of that book is
[ __ ] insane you guys michaela his
daughter wrote a book about her all meat
diet
and the cover is truly
insane um here it is
yeah dude what the [ __ ] he did he does
look good he looks great he looks great
there he does not look like that anymore
adam he looks
like also the funniest thing is like
this cover like did she make it herself
it has real like graphic design as my
passion energy yeah eight different
fonts on there it's like
the placement is all wrong jordan
peterson looks like a tiny person like
and he's in front of her
yeah it's so strange like how did you
make this dude it's it's art this is
literally this is art it reminds me of
like us like a landing page from the 90s
that's like a total scam
it's so good
it's it's it's great i respect that
what's the bottom say how to cure
depression and disease with meat only
[ __ ] you really you're a phd
psychologist and you put that on a book
you quack ass [ __ ] uh yeah she let him
see he saw it he's called i guess they
co-wrote it yeah yeah jordan and
michaela peterson didn't this came out
right
like within a year before his whole like
medical
breakdown right yes yes oops yes that
didn't work yeah yeah he he started
doing this and then apple cider almost
killed him and then benzos almost killed
him right and then covet almost killed
him yes
all directly related to michaela peters
yes
yes through dragons chaos yes
all right let's finish this because this
is the best part but yeah the
exploitation concept is like really
silly because you know
what what's up like parents are
exploiting their children when they
instill confidence in them by saying you
can actually be good at soccer if you
try hard enough that's [ __ ] tell
them they're destined for a lifetime of
failure instead
sorry it's not be honest your kid is
just not good
he's a [ __ ] loser yeah
i stop parents when i see them
complimenting their children i say don't
do it be honest for once in your life
men
your kid is ugly
he's a pathetic [ __ ] loser yes he's
gonna die alone yeah make sure you're
less confident so they'll become ample
servile little piglets for my self-help
he's gonna need 12 steps
and another 12
maybe even another 12 year son [ __ ]
sucks yeah
your son's gonna need all 36 steps
and that's that
yeah be honest
your little girl's looking a little
chubby there bucko
oh god yeah jordan peterson yelling at
parents because he can't jerk off to
their daughters
excuse me what do you mean i can't go
back to the playground
this is where i find out whether the
next generation will be sexy or not
excuse me ma'am i can't but help but
notice your 12 year old girl is eating
ice cream
she's a little overweight don't you
think yeah it's just
dude that's the best part about like
politics in the way that it is now and
the way that it's consumed now is like
normally in every other uh in every
other period in time and throughout
history that guy would have been like
you're a psycho get the [ __ ] away from
me right like that would be the reaction
but now it's like actually that man is a
brilliant uh intellectual thinker a
giant uh a a pillar of success and uh
and that's why i'm black building don't
you
because people like ted cruz
are taken seriously yeah and it's just
like okay well
ted cruz is like barely a [ __ ] human
being so
all right let's just finish this clip
out
but they're still exploiting her so
don't pull any moral stunts on me
because you're irritated about my
opinion when it's bloody clear to
anybody with eyes that that was
manipulative in 20 different ways not
everyone's a genius not everyone's
picasso not everyone's young and healthy
not everyone is a sports illustrated
swimsuit model period because so
if you don't like it
oh he's getting spicy with it you need
jordan i don't like jordan without
benzos he's too we need to get him back
no i love this this is my favorite
jordan peterson i've actually decided
like i want him to weekly tell us like
what he can't jerk off to and then have
like all of his [ __ ] fan base be like
yeah this is this is intellectual
thought
this week i opened uh
a pornhub
and i noticed
there was a bbw
yeah
and i couldn't and she was way too fat
so i clicked off that one
i want to only watch [ __ ] hypno this is
okay
it's okay when you watch it it's all
right
[Music]
[ __ ] you and then i saw a young lady she
had a giant dildo she was peg it's
called pegging
and i was very intrigued by that and
that's
i mean it is fine
yeah that's what you're into i don't
think she was stroking herself
absent-mindedly and then i saw one about
my grandma a girl a a guilf okay that's
not fine and i thought to myself boy
she reminds me of my grandma i'm i'm not
key shaming except for that one thing
that he wrote in his book about his
grandmother's pubic hair that's like
don't do that sometimes i think about my
grandmother when i masturbate it had the
appearance of a thick mat of hair oh she
had long pubic hairs that stretched down
to her ankles her genital region was
exposed dimly when i was a child i'd
shower with my grandma and swing on her
pubes like monkey bars okay okay okay i
let her have her way
[ __ ] you sometimes i'd wear her pubes
like a scarf
and pretend i was little red riding hood
and [ __ ] you if you don't like it
[ __ ] you
my grandma's meat curtains are low as
well okay okay
we gotta stop we gotta stop please
please [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
thank you jordan i agree with you on
that one
he's so funny though he's he is actually
a ray of light and otherwise dark
and miserable landscape i think him he
makes me very happy it makes me very
happy when he's running around talking
about what he what upsets him that he
can't jerk off to and like for those of
you say like back in the day he used to
do more serious commentary he's like no
he literally would talk about frozen and
[ __ ] dawg he was more serious he's
really lost his mind
he wasn't this off the rails bro he was
he was trying to apply like jungian uh
you know uh critique on to you know
popular culture and and doing a horrible
job at it too like it was just
dude he wasn't as off the rails man he's
[ __ ] off the rails bro i don't know i
think he's always off the rails i think
people just didn't know yeah exactly
he wasn't on twitter being like [ __ ] you
if you think she's pretty yeah he was
cute writing in his book about how he
fantasized about beating up children
though that's true oh for real i haven't
read that exercise you know that's in
the bible as a bald man you perhaps
should read it
30 bears come attacking the children for
making fun of a bald man
that's right that's in the old testament
the good one baldophobia is a real crime
uh here again i'm about to get
blackpilled again
well okay well that's like this is you
know speaking of speaking of [ __ ]
psychos on the on the main this is great
um let's just let's watch this let's i
love louis gomer incredible incredible
development merrick garland's doj
actually coming after now
trump administration officials for their
failure to import with this political
committee yep
it it actually puts an exclamation point
on the fact
that we have a two-tiered justice system
uh if you're a republican you can't even
lie to congress and lie to an fbi agent
bro you just described like straight up
felonies yeah
if you're a republican you can no longer
whip your dick out in a bowling alley
and then uh you know expose yourself to
minors like
like lauren bobert's beautiful husband
did
you know i swear to god this country is
going to hell i can't even lie to the
fbi or congress yeah it's awesome yeah
what the [ __ ] bro did you just say
yeah he's just he's just saying it out
loud dude he's on newsmax this is like
when they they
yeah yeah nobody watches it except for
like literally brain damaged uh 65 year
olds so it's not even that much crazier
than fox news to be honest with you dude
it's not it's it's really not but
uh if you're a republican you can't even
lie to congress
or lied to an fbi
are they're coming after you they're
going to bury you they're going to put
you in the dc jail and terrorize and
torture you and not live up to the
constitution there who's being what
we're pumped for
i love i love republicans turning into
like angela davis and and becoming
prison abolitionist the moment that they
like have to undergo like a fraction of
the scrutiny that like a black person
what republican is being tortured in
jail for relating to the fbi no you
don't understand ethan
the carceral state is exploitative and
inhumane we must abolish prisons now for
republicans only we need to strengthen
the security of our justice our
republican justices
no it's just uh it's it's great it's
wonderful uh i love when politicians
just come out and and openly just stated
how it is it's just like i should be
able to lie to the fbi um i can't even
lie to my dates about having a hair
piece yeah it's illegal speaking of what
he looks like i think louis gomer looks
like the the bald eagle on sesame street
for the record like straight up a
one-to-one
comparison yeah that man has a clean
[ __ ] dome y'all yeah
i respect that nobody no one does that
kind of bald anymore they always shave
it off
yeah yeah he's got that they always
shave it off
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i respect the way
what the [ __ ]
all right let's [ __ ] eagles sam the
eagle we got a bus world that's what i
was talking about yeah we already had an
hour and a half and we haven't done [ __ ]
why is he saluting hitler bro yeah well
i don't know why he's throwing up what's
going on damn the eagle
all right let's keep heals of susan
being acquitted because the jury that
had a bunch of hillary clinton lovers in
it donors even
they said look uh you know
he's a democrat and
of course they're going to lie everybody
lies how about that jury
no big deal
and the fbi everybody yeah
literally lying
dude that's
jesus that i i love that that's great
he's right yeah the juries are tainted
the pools are chained by uh democrats
who love to lie and are letting the
democrats get away with crimes
and republicans should be able to get
away with crimes too that's his argument
i guess
that's what he's saying you remember how
angry
all these reactionary [ __ ] got at me
for saying someone should b word the nra
um
oh yeah i do remember that that was your
8 21 moment yeah so so how do you think
they're responding to this clip
what does god say is the answer is the
solution for the homosexual in 2022 here
in the new testament here in the book of
romans that they are worthy of death
these people should be put to death
every single homosexual in our country
should be charged with the crime the
abomination of homosexuality that they
have they should be convicted in a
lawful trial they should be sentenced
with death they should be lined up
against the wall and shot in the back of
the head
okay can i suggest you move just you
might like saudi arabia or some [ __ ]
like that i mean you're a wrong person
oh they would line him up in saudi
arabia because he looks like a like a
little twink there i mean i'm gonna be
honest
not every not every gay per i mean the
the idea that like every homophobic
person is gay secretly is [ __ ]
obviously there's plenty of stray people
but
look i've been living in west hollywood
for what [ __ ] 10 years now and i've
seen that dude okay
that dude is like a pete buddha judge
voter you know what i mean he's like
yeah i work for defense contractors like
he looks literally like my neighbors
that are
you know they put up like their [ __ ]
rick caruso law signs you know what i
mean like and and
he just
no but but on a serious note again i
mean this this is beyond disturbing like
this is just intolerable i mean
they're like this is [ __ ] insane i
mean and it goes beyond just
rhetoric he's really calling for
violence i mean yeah this this this this
is just
this is [ __ ] horrific um
and you know
i'm sorry but this [ __ ] cannot be
tolerated i mean what the [ __ ] is this
so there's also a difference between
like what you said and what he's saying
because like the state is currently
working on efforts to criminalize
homosexuality or or write it out of
existence by starting off with trans
people and then moving quickly into gay
territory as well so if you're
comfortable in that uh seed if you're
like a cis
uh if you're like uh if you feel like a
cisgender uh white gay guy and you think
like oh they won't come for me like uh
no they will actually look at [ __ ]
florida right and they moved on so
quickly from like not allowing trans
women all four of them in like whatever
[ __ ] state they're in from
participating in like athletic
competition at any level to literally
just being like we need to ban hormone
therapy in its entirety um and they will
very quickly once they seize power on
that front move on to gay people again
um and so when a person like this comes
out and is justifying that state
violence and is asking for more that is
significantly more damaging than uh than
anyone pushing against uh the the
violence that is uh structural and
normalized uh like
the nra like what the nra agitates for
on a daily basis by uh ensuring that
americans have easily readily accessible
weapons and an arsenal that they can use
in any given moment
i just again this is just like a
black-pilled moment like i don't even
know what the [ __ ] to say about this
this should not this man should not
[ __ ] exist i mean this is disgusting
dude
i wish someone just [ __ ] [ __ ]
already and get on with it bro just
become the new you i mean who's you just
to say that's not happening you know
what i mean
it's just uh yeah uh that that
he looks like a cream pie [ __ ]
i mean he he just like i said i've seen
dudes
like this dude looks like my neighbors
like i can't i can't lie about it he
just straight up looks like he would be
having a wonderful life
with a husband named ted you know what i
mean and they have like their nice
little [ __ ] designer dog that is like
dying okay i don't know how the [ __ ]
this dog is still alive it's like it's
got the eye boogers it's like like half
dead walking like limping and [ __ ] and
like they're taking care of this [ __ ]
dog and they're spending ten thousand
dollars a year making sure the dog is
alive okay
and that's it that's that's the they
live a comfortable life working at a
[ __ ] agit agency in a different
universe yeah
and that's that
yeah but here he is trying to make his
dad happy
uh who's like grew up all of his life
here and i [ __ ] hate the gays i wish
they'd all die and he's like oh [ __ ] i
guess i better please daddy but then
meanwhile he goes oh daddy i wish you
[ __ ] my [ __ ] when he jerks it at
night yeah i mean dude that's
you know
it is what it is but he's for sure the
type of guy who would like get outed by
like a
a male prostitute he's like yeah no we
used to smoke meth and [ __ ] all night
that's very i mean that's a real yeah
yeah yeah
oh this guy who says death to the gays
man that you'd suck dick harder than a
[ __ ] used to suck my dick like a
gardener yeah listen if you're if you're
a [ __ ] louisiana top okay it's your
duty to ensure okay that everybody knows
that this dude loves to get his back
walls what's his name what's his name uh
i'm dylan oz
i will protect you oh dylan i'm in awe
of how good you suck that dick why
listen i'm telling you what dude i'm
gonna say this normally i'm for bottoms
rights
okay bottoms need to unionize bottoms
all the way and you're selfish stay out
of this one but if you're a selfish top
you have to [ __ ] out this man okay
straight up i touch you what man i will
defend you i'll protect you i would suck
a watermelon through a garden hose i
whoo
you know what i'm saying
i'll make you come in in 30 seconds i'll
tell you what any debt
big or small my name is
i represent steadfast and that's how i
like to make my partners come once again
so this does not mean that like every
homophobic person is uh repressed and
and secretly gay obviously there's
plenty of straight [ __ ] weirdos that
are uh you know
incredibly homophobic
i'm just saying that he he you know
he's a little close to home uh with the
way that he carries himself in the way
your dick's feeling a little small just
shove you on your whole hand up there
now boy okay all right let's
either you're gonna get canceled again
well i'm just saying he's probably a
freak he likes butt or like freaky you
know he likes the butt stuff just saying
get your whole foot up there now boy
let me get let me let me uh
what do you call it when you prolapse
let's stop talking about this let's stop
yes let's roses move on let's get shut
up deck is it really that bad everyone's
telling me to stop no it's so it's all
good if i said your last major
cancellation
topic we should probably think here's
the thing like um i've already said some
saucy [ __ ] from this from the jump by
being like he looks gay which is already
like teetering along the edge of
unacceptability regard uh depending on
how charitable you are about like my
background personally in my opinion
whatever we're saying it's just to [ __ ]
with this guy he hates gay people i just
want i just want more people to start
calling him gay because it's going to
piss him off
or he can just live a comfortable life
he could just be you be me that's pride
month ben
when is better to come out than now
no but what do you call when the
prolapse people are saying a blossom a
rose
it's uh what do you call when it's a
pink blossom i think pink yeah
pro so i think he's into prolapsing and
stuff like that a rosebud
is what it is you've seen that darley no
i have not actually i have not seen that
and i would like to keep it that way i
think
i'm i'm good on that front i'm not
weaponizing homosexuality stop i talk
about everyone
this man says he wants to gate kill gay
people and you're mad at us stop it
um i'm on your side damn it anyway let's
let's just move on let's move on from
steadfast in the most steadfast way
possible
yes in a just world uh in a uh you know
in a
in a just world this person would not be
able to get away with saying [ __ ] like
this obviously and uh i don't know which
community he's a part of but
uh i suspect that um you know
hold on hold on hold on step fast church
is a uh is a baptist church
i mean i'm not surprised by that guys i
am not saying being gay is bad i don't
know what how you can twist my words
into that this man is saying he thinks
gay people should die okay
i don't think i think being gay is as
natural as being straight
there's nothing [ __ ] wrong with it in
the least bit okay
stop all i'm saying is look
he much like josh ali has a body fat
percentage okay
that screams he likes to go to the gym
and if you live in [ __ ] louisiana or
whatever baptist uh the part of [ __ ]
town you live in if you got pectorals
like that okay that are that i can
[ __ ] sense from inside of your
goddamn uh suit then you know it's a
little sus it's gay as [ __ ] to go to the
gym i say this as someone who goes to
the gym all the goddamn time it is the
gayest thing you can do okay what's up
dude you're trying to get [ __ ] jacked
so the other dudes can look at you check
you out that's what that's what my man
is doing and that's where my speculation
is is coming from okay also josh hawley
look up josh holly kissing his wife if
you want to know what i'm talking about
or josh hawley at whole foods
we've looked at it on the show wait josh
before
holly there you have it
dude that is it bro why are you pucking
your lip that's like when you kiss your
mom
brady kisses his children harder than
josh
what the [ __ ] is that kiss from gary vee
kisses dad harder than that man he's
literally puckering his lips no josh
holly josh only kisses his wife like a
like a k drama
wait where's the whole foods pick i want
that one i haven't seen that one i'll
just give you a big fat kiss
oh [ __ ] bro i'm sorry guys but dude come
on
he is too he keeps it tight dude okay
he's fit he keeps [ __ ] tight
he's super sass
[Laughter]
interesting wow yeah what's up dude why
are you why are you keeping it so tight
what's going on who are you trying to
impress with that dude with your with
your [ __ ] side boob
love
i love that someone snapped this creeper
photo of him like it's in the middle of
the day too
it looks like uh he's posing to be
honest yeah he looks good he keeps it
[ __ ] tight
he'd be very popular but i think he
probably is very popular
man
all right guys can i i'll just say
apologies if i said something offensive
you know i'm deeply sorry you know i
love the gays
we love the gays here folks
we love them
but let's focus on this guy who says he
wants to primarily gay people pride
month ethan is going to take steroids
and start thirst trapping for the gays
in order to accommodate
hell yeah
you know it does it does okay let's just
move on
um so that he also by the way he also
said sodomites are responsible for
school shootings and actively celebrate
those tragedies the hate the hate
preacher yeah yeah the same guy
in that same sermon which is pretty
funny because he's literally advocating
to like line up gay people and kill them
but then also simultaneously being like
but it's terrible when shootings happen
because of gay people like what the [ __ ]
they're the violent ones yeah
yeah uh incredible stuff
i mean but i guess my theory on this
thing of like people who who like
homosexuality occupies that much of
their mind is just
i just like
it's like you think about gay people all
day they're responsible for everything
same totally dude i swear to god it's
just weird however there's so many
people transphobic people [ __ ] like
they are pathologically obsessed with
trans people that's why so many of them
are [ __ ] chasers too like alex jones
or you know the other nazi that i will
not be [ __ ] yeah that one dude uh
well i know you don't like to name him
but yeah he got he one of his tabs was
like uh cute sussy or cute uh yes big
lipstick boy getting railed by chicken
girl i love that [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
they're chasers and they hate it like
the thing is
like wait a chaser what does that mean a
chaser is just like a person that
fetishizes trans people and and like
exclusively is like trying to [ __ ] trans
people because they're trans
like wait you think they're trans
no no no no because
excuse me [ __ ] the trans people because
they they fetishize trans people okay i
gotcha um
and it's objectification
obviously i mean this is like higher
level lgbt conversations but
um
ultimately i think it's come it stems
from a place of like a rigid gender
rigid understanding of gender that's
antiquated outdated
that and also homophobia and transphobia
because trans people are at the
intersection of all of these bigotries
like different bigotries misogyny as
well so when they like i think they get
like horny for a lot of these like
really [ __ ] big high-level um
right-wingers when they get horny for
trans people
that pisses them off they get like
frustrated because they want to see like
and suck girl dick and that
confuses them like they can't they're
like well i'm not straight anymore like
then i'm does that mean i'm gay and oh
that's that's terrible so we should like
eliminate trans people you know
non-stop he goes you know what would
help these urges that make me
uncomfortable killing all gay people
yeah i mean
then i wouldn't have to deal with these
urges yeah and uh it's simple healthier
ways to deal with it
just suck a dick dude it's it's fine you
know what i mean maybe you'll like it he
will
guarantee it if you haven't already um
okay let's talk let's move on to uh you
know the left camp meme this [ __ ]
benny
whatever the [ __ ] his name is we've
missed mazzy we've missed this guy who
plagiarized from buzzfeed and then
joined uh
[Applause]
soyboy johnson yeah the left camp meme
part two
what a king this guy is such a [ __ ]
loser dude holy [ __ ]
this show is just an abomination of god
this is the comedy equivalent of ted
cruz saying we need one door at schools
[Applause]
again the the one constant throughout
this show every episode is this one
screaming girl from like 15 years ago or
something
they cannot let it go and it's just
amazing
here we go let's just watch a little bit
there's two episodes
[Applause]
again i just love the the subtext of
this it's like supreme court has voted
to overturn abortion rights it's like oh
liberal [ __ ] losers just lost the
right to control their own bodies chill
it's not that serious of course when
you're incredibly and profoundly
privileged like that's your only stake
that's your only [ __ ] um you know
that's the only involvement that you
have in the conversation because you're
not thinking about like your wife or
your daughter uh
uh perhaps having need uh for medical
care in a similar uh capacity you will
probably take care of that if the if the
time ever comes you know what i mean or
your mistress well benny johnson might
actually not be involved in any of that
because there is at least ample evidence
that he likes to go to gay cruises oh
more gay stuff uh he i'm trying to
get benny johnson that was when he saw
that yeah
okay let's just i'll buy it i'll buy it
i'll buy it i'll bite benny johnson no
no no no no that's a big reveal later
just okay continue i'll show you what i
mean by that but we need to have it on
all these conservative closeted dudes on
a big old cruise and just [ __ ]
yeah just and they couldn't fly the
rainbow flag
no cameras
no phones
um they could be like yo should we kill
ourselves right now
no they they but because they think you
know
okay yeah they they
well let's let's just watch this for a
second but like what i'm trying to say
i'm trying what i'm trying to say here
with uh with benny johnson and with the
supreme court stuff is that like for
conservatives they have no involvement
they always know they can pay they
always know they can pay their way if if
need be if the need arises for them to
like actually
get this medical treatment they'll
figure out a way but um but on the other
hand like this is this is just like fun
for them you know i mean they're like
owning the [ __ ] libs and owning women
and that's like sick
i mean just showing like ah triggered
caring about having bodily autonomy it's
like well even if you
are
pro if you're in favor of forced birth
you can at least understand that why
women would want
the right to choose but okay no this is
just for memes
[Music]
i [ __ ] owned l
l force birth
again welcome back to the left can't
meme the title makes absolutely no sense
we love this show this is the show
devoted to all the memes you're not
allowed to talk about or share on other
platforms that's why we are on parlor
partnering with free you can find any of
those on any platform the reason people
don't share it is because they're not
funny and also like he's literally if
you know he's
if these are real means he's probably
taking him off other platforms anyway
exactly
the real like gab memes are literally
just like holocaust was good you know
what i mean like they have no they their
brains are so [ __ ] rotted where it's
like nazi pedophiles being like uh you
know doing like lolliporn and [ __ ] so
obviously for them
uh that's the real left can't meme [ __ ]
you would be showing like all this
groiper stuff not this [ __ ] tame ass
like boomer conservative uh you know uh
soy jack uh lady [ __ ] crying over and
over again
free speech platform and megaphone
parlor in order to bring you the memes
that will make the libs cry salty salted
tears that flow through the streets
gushing with old faithful level saul i'm
gonna be honest with you he brought up
old faithful in the last show like he
literally you want you want to know
something
range
i think this is the most like [ __ ]
version of this show you could ever get
and here's why
even anti-sjws
in like 2016 when they were 2015 that
are now like reform don't believe in any
of that [ __ ] anymore like any anti-sjw
video essays that you could watch in
2016 would already be making like way
worse comparisons by like pointing to a
black person and then pointing to a
monkey you know what i mean in the memes
itself like that was like [ __ ] that even
[ __ ] centrists were do
centrists were doing in like 2015 2014
and and especially during the gamergate
era so this guy
going on [ __ ] parlor and being like
these are memes that are too hard and
then only showing like the the soy rage
uh woman
shows me that like
there is yeah it's it's super satisfying
it's totally sanitized it's like yeah
it's just not funny bro
you know
and it's not well let's watch because
they're losing they're safe
here sacramento
yes
let's make fun of these monsters and
these absolute death cult members in
their desire to murder more babies and
let's rejoice that we live inside of a
country that is ensconced in our
constitution life liberty pursuit of
happiness that's so whack like what that
none of this is going to trigger the
libs dog like do you got to be way more
racist and way more [ __ ] openly
anti-lgbt they'll like get anyone mad
the guy can't keep track of what he's
saying he goes these [ __ ] death
cultists want to choose what to do with
their own body well we're here to pursue
liberty
and the pursuit of happiness unless
you're you know like what the [ __ ]
unless you're a 14 year old that was a
victim of incestuous rape uh in which
case no liberty or pursuit of happiness
for you we are going to forcibly make
sure you carry that pregnancy to term
love that yeah exactly great great dude
he has such incredible cognitive
dissonance that he can actually put all
that in the same sentence
it's crazy but chiefly among all these
life
life okay all lives matter
unless they're unless they're
all lives matter
dude unless they're a bunch of 12 year
olds at elementary school you're wrong
ethan i love i love turning on the
parlor app with my 60 year old father
and you know
getting a good uh laugh out of watching
fetuses on the benny johnson show this
is mmm makes you laugh
where's the jokes been what this is this
is
liberalism this is actually the same uh
one of my good friends felix biederman
chabo trap house always says but like
everyone in america is the same that
everyone has become like a liberal the
the aesthetics uh focused like a trying
to be civil attitude that liberals have
always had has completely seeped into
the republican party as well and that's
precisely why
this
is the lin-manuel miranda of of [ __ ]
republican [ __ ] like they want you to
laugh but they also want you to think
now if you remove the violent uh
attitude the violent ideology and just
look at purely the rhetoric itself
and the goal of this video you will
recognize that what benny johnson is
trying to do is basically the same as
like uh you know when liberals say we
need to like clean up uh you know all of
our movies to make sure that only good
messages are being presented like the
hero is a good guy no no room for bad
guys like i hate what was it chocolate
licorice or whatever licorice pizza yeah
the
[ __ ] uh movie that came out recently
where they were like well that's like
there was some you know underlying pedo
stuff there like it's unacceptable right
um
that that like uh that manicured uh
messaging is happening here as well with
benny johnson which memes are not
supposed to be like that which is why
this is he hasn't even told us
hilariously awful let's just say i'm
inside your walls ben i'm inside your
uterus ben
save me ben
you can't have an america without life
we are a country of life not a country
of death and so ladies and gentlemen
please join me on a wonderful pro-life
meme journey here let's go oh this is
gonna be so fun
can you even name one rule
men have over their bodies pardon me
ma'am i just got drafted to go die in
ward
that's
no but like but like is that a good
thing to be drafted to go to [ __ ] war
like i don't think that's a good thing
you know well his point is that oh well
you don't have control it's like no we
we get drafted into war
okay so that hasn't happened he's
admitting he's like yes so we're taking
away your right
to control your body what are you
jealous like
you're jealous that like they weren't
after they go
yeah you know um also when yeah when's
the last time there was a draft it's
been like
it doesn't matter we got poverty draft
baby
exactly
don't worry we got plenty of poor people
and recruiters yeah
i saw a video of the new top gun where
army recruiters were outside the theater
i was like man that is [ __ ] that [ __ ]
was that movie was uh cool as [ __ ] i've
heard it but that army recruiting [ __ ]
is now i would if i was younger i'd be
like yeah hell yeah i'm joining the air
force
the original top gun famously caused
like a massive spike in in navy
recruitment because everybody wanted to
go be on an airplane and then they all
said why the [ __ ] did i do this yeah
don't join the army please i'm just
telling you don't join the military it's
not like you're just gonna ruin your
yeah and also you're not going to be a
[ __ ] dog fighter you are going to
you're going to be
just a dog well that but just like they
mentioned in the beginning of the top
gun you're going to be sitting in a
[ __ ] nevada facility okay uh dropping
[ __ ] drones uh 6 000 miles away on
some yemeni uh wedding so
don't do that
it's bad
ma'am i just got drafted to go die in
ward
dude why are you showing people dying
and saving private ryan what's wrong
with you dude because that's the only
thing
justifiable active dude why so long
chill what the [ __ ] dude
what is that person it's uh it's a
social justice warrior
i love when conservatives do this
because like they're so ugly yeah have
you seen mitch mcconnell bro like i love
that yeah you've seen do you think that
you're more [ __ ] than mitch mc look
at mitch mcconnell that man if you
if you [ __ ] mitch mcconnell you would
like your [ __ ] would shrivel up in
clothes
it's like when mitch mcconnell puts his
dick inside you it's like cauterizing a
wound your [ __ ] just closed up jesus i
mean it's true
his dick's like a lightsaber just
[ __ ] caught right
now i kind of want to wait i know mitch
mcconnell's wife is uh uh
she's like um
is she like some horrible [ __ ] no no
she yeah she is she uh elaine chan she
is a uh
she's like a is she like a chinese
shipping magnate or something yeah
something like that yeah she was the
united states secretary of
transportation in the trump
administration from 2017 to 2021
and also the
secretary labor under the bush
administration
um she was the first asian american
woman to ever serve in a presidential
cabinet slay queen
um and i think she has like multiple
billions of dollars oh oh
yeah she's taiwanese and immigrated to
the united states when she was eight
years old
she's actually really pretty she
really yeah i mean mitch did
yeah
way above his weight here 100 but well
what did mitch look like back in the day
was he handsome
the oldest one i can think of is like
when he's sitting in front of that
confederate flag
you know what i'm talking about and he
looks like [ __ ] there too
oh god oh god oh well at least she
looked human he's never really a looker
he's not handsome but he looks human at
least yeah he definitely swung way above
his weight class with elaine yeah my
queen
all right let's see where you're going
with this gremlin sjw
reviews do you have sex with you
yeah right you know that all the girls
that there's like smoking hot
[ __ ]
supermodel babes who hate your guts bro
so no it's just it's like oh we want you
look at this ugly uh
it's not gonna happen anyway it's like
uh dude benny no one's trying to [ __ ]
you dog what the [ __ ] do you mean like
there's no one
is benny johnson had consensual sex with
a woman i [ __ ] doubt it
like well it seems like he's trying to
go on some cruises more than anything
does he have a wife oh he does kate
johnson oh poor soul sorry to break into
you sorry no
i don't want to be the bearer of bad
news but yeah that's um okay should we
reveal it i have it on standby oh you
want to show it here let's show it there
you go
the advertising on the military times
right now this was the dude this is the
best thing i've ever seen he goes
the man gets a a self you know and self
generated by your own
google search the world's largest gay
crews get on board do you know how much
gauge porn you have to be looking up to
get that at yeah that is like an
extremely targeted ad they don't waste
their money on
straight men incognito browsers like i
don't understand like i don't even look
at
i don't look at my porn on on my regular
browser regardless you know what i mean
like i don't understand how he [ __ ]
was like i want those cookies did he did
he erase
that show the response the response was
great
i did i want to embrace this this was
just like from a news article to me well
the top responses like benny those are
for based on your google
yeah
so you know i've never got in a world's
largest gay cruise ad nope
neither have i
uh
not you know just yeah he deleted it
i [ __ ] owned bro i just like
i mean of course he did
no i was just doing research bro yeah
yeah he was looking at what he was
trying to do yeah i was just trying to
figure out what cruisers to avoid
i don't want any gay people on my
cruises
yo i just i [ __ ] hate cruises anyway
but that's a that's just so so cam went
to the military times and he got an
adobe ad yeah nerd sense right yeah
freaking nerd dude oh nice bro
i'm just saying here let's see what i
get let's play a little game you got no
gay cruise ads let's see if what i get
this isn't my personal computer so it's
not going to be super accurate but i
mean we've looked up some weird [ __ ]
here i was just going to say well let's
see let's see weird [ __ ] oh i have i
have blanc
[Music]
and let's see what dan because this is
like dan's oh that's ila's computer oh
zealous oh yes
again it's not
we it's not
[Music]
you know any any gay cruz search results
i'm just trying to turn off adblock
make it your home
va loans apply now
ea loans yeah that's weird veterans
first mortgage
[Music]
orthopedic fee relief uh pain relief
shoes
these are all over the place is that
music coming in an ad that's playing
that's me website
i just got square which is i guess
pretty good navy federal credit union
save every month oh i got va loans as
well
new walk-in tubs on sale no gape cruises
though weird
no we're all the good cruises wait let's
do an experiment i can do one of you
guys might do an experiment for me sure
just go on google just look up a bunch
of gay related stuff
maybe some gay porn just type gate you
don't have to open it just type gay porn
and stuff and then go to military times
no just google gatekeepers
like gay cruz
crews look up gay parties
i'm gonna click through on like the
first four
links here okay oh wait i just got a
queer as folk ad guys oh that doesn't
count as peacock
right yeah that's just nbc all right now
military times
well ben he's like see you got a you got
a gay ad
nah bro
uh
cbs
it was a failed experiment after opening
all the gay crews yeah you got to be
looking you got to be looking at a lot
more gay stuff all right
all right i'm going in to get to benny
johnson's level of
gay targeting yeah you've got to spend
more time in it while we while dan and
amy conduct that experiment let's
continue
disgusting
was it worth it mommy no
yeah
that one's awesome
yeah she's in hell
mommy's burning in hell because she got
an abortion i love that that's that's
good yeah that's great that's what they
fantasize about too yeah you're gonna
burn in hell not not benny though he's
definitely going to heaven for sure
yeah i love how a baby who's like not a
brain hasn't even formed is in heaven
being like mommy you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
why is the baby so sanctimonious like
shut up [ __ ] like you went directly to
heaven if anything like what about what
about original sin that baby didn't even
get baptized that's okay well oh damn
you're right that baby go to hell too oh
good point just saying good point all
i'm saying is if you got a [ __ ] fast
track like you know uh a fast pass to
heaven like what the [ __ ] why are you
still being like so uh vicious like what
you wanted to get owned and like you
wanna work at a [ __ ] [ __ ] job for
like 60 years before you [ __ ] killed
yourself and then actually went to hell
shut up baby you [ __ ] you made it
okay
right don't baby does if
the
aborted fetus goes to heaven
how does that work does it just stay as
like a helpless like fetus in heaven for
all of eternity no yeah because here
they depict it they're like well what
happens is he's just a little older he's
like a toddler so he can talk no [ __ ]
no he's in a he's in a uh purgatory
state of [ __ ] suspended
liv he's in that baby's in hell it's
just like a pustule of uh yeah of cells
the size of a [ __ ] pinky too like
it's not you know it really really
wasn't eight dollars an hour thirty
dollars an hour one hundred dollars an
hour priceless oh what's funny about
that dude that's just like weird boomers
oh priceless you literally pulled this
from like the [ __ ] most vanilla
facebook page for christian boomers you
should be embarrassed bro i love this
they're trying to like
dude this is so tame it's just not gonna
you're not hitting this is not hitting
you're on parlor man you gotta be
talking we need nazi salutes we need
[ __ ] pedo [ __ ] you know what i mean
we need like really not the libs are so
nice minorities being like hung and
explain
and you know what i'm saying he's not
he's not hitting we need ice breaking
down doors [ __ ] like that's happening in
real life so
you know thank you to the supreme court
in their 60 year decision that was very
nice of them to do so yes awesome super
constitutional
gun owners if you ban abortions women
will just get them illegally
i love the buyer logic [ __ ] because like
okay then the reverse is true as well
like
what the [ __ ] do you mean
like right it goes both ways you say
you're not against gun owners
you say you're yeah it's like bro so why
make abortion of google then owned yeah
it's a cell phone it's also like you're
not born with a gun dumb ass like you
can you can personally you know also
it's not dangerous it's not like life
potentially life
threatening to go buy a gun it is
potentially life-threatening if you're a
black woman who's pregnant in america
though statistically speaking so exactly
there is that reality don't you
understand how hard this owns you you
[ __ ] degenerate loser
brain rotted [ __ ] freak
yeah i love that it's great
this is black building me son
everything's black building yeah you
just keep it rolling dude how are you
getting black about benny johnson bro
because this is like it's just nobody's
we're literally the only people that
watch this ethan this shouldn't don't
let this oh but it's a symptom it's all
[ __ ] a symptom of this
of this cancer of stupidity they don't
there's just people are so [ __ ]
stupid that you can go on a national
stage and say things this stupid like
ted cruz saying we need less doors i
mean that man should be laughed out of
public
office he should not be taken seriously
and yet he is i'm just saying like there
needs to be a limit on how stupid you
can be how brazenly pathetic
you can miss a point how bad openly bad
faith you can take something and but but
there's no limit there's no [ __ ]
limit and it's black it's because it's
team sports though because like it does
your audience likes it but this is the
same it's just there's one door at an
elementary school it's so
it's but
his audience is that [ __ ] stupid oh
so he can get away with saying really
stupid [ __ ] as long as he's like the
right team he's on the right team
dude
liberals do it too to be fair lotus
makes a ruling libs scotus makes a
ruling libs
we said we're doing abortion today
that's awesome he's trying to do this oh
he's trying to do black voice i love
that okay give me some more of that
that's what i want to see right right
right that's right that's what i want to
see have you ever heard of stephen
crowder steven crowder has one [ __ ]
oh he loves he has one black scent okay
whether it's obama or morgan freeman
it's always this like cartoonish like
insane i will not even do it i will not
even attempt it
it's psychotic yeah it's like roots
yeah it's uh yeah kkk
it's you know because that's what
happens when you've like never been
around a black per like a single black
person
other than you know let's move on next
step because so this one's all about you
know abortion okay benny
this is crazy [ __ ] and then so let's
move it on
uh to the episode three
which was about um
guns
oh my god hold on
go ahead did you get it did you get the
gay ad no i didn't i got something
better actually
because i just said where the don't get
let this bother you were the only people
watching this i decided let me go to
parlor and go to benny johnson's page
and check out how many views this is
getting
a fourth episode of this came out last
week
he has
zero interactions and that's an
exaggeration oh no
wait how much does that say for parlor
that more people are watching it on
twitter twitter
making fun of them wait click that is
this really the landing page does that
play the video yes
he has zero comments 1980 what about the
last and this was posted a week ago
this is
this is no different
than a money laundering operation do you
understand what is happening here is
exactly what happens with every
institution that is like designed to
propagandize right-wing positions we
still do not know who funds the
federalist which is a paper in
circulation that probably reaches like
30 people okay and yet they're still
able to write articles these are this is
a jobs program for reactionary psychos
because billionaires and millionaires
that fund these operations understand
that like there is utility to uh to
keeping up appearances and having these
like uh having a steady flow of
propaganda some of it will hit a lot of
it won't but at the very least like
msnbc will have you on as a contributor
so you can actually reach an audience
like that's broader or fox news
obviously fox news does have a
legitimate audience but outside of that
like there are so many things like this
uh that that are kept alive exclusively
by generous donations from billionaires
and millionaires propped up by think
tanks
with the express purpose of trying to
propagandize positions and they go on
for far too long regardless of
performance it's it's always the case
they recognize propaganda i mean how
important can you look at the last
episode dan is do any of them have any
comments i just want to make sure we're
understanding this right like there
should be at least one comment from his
mom or something on one of them well i
don't know like as i was explaining i
mean i don't think anybody actually used
to
show me the third episode in the sec i
just want to see it there i'm going back
anything on any of them i post on parlor
quite a bit um
yeah i talk to myself too sometimes yeah
i mean that's literally what's going on
yeah
uh there's episode four that i just
looked at uh
left camp meme exclusively
harrison you thirsty
what do you
hold it up to his mouth
here take a sip
oh yeah
that's teamwork baby
[Applause]
yes dude
i've been scrolling this whole time
is there an example of a parlor post
that actually does have any comments
i think that's what he's trying to find
out right okay i mean maybe parlor
doesn't show comments at all right
that's right
zero echo zero uh votes everything has
zeros i'm like spot checking all of his
posts now find any post with any likes
zero zero zero i mean i guess like
people moved on from parliament
right but even truth social doesn't have
any activity right it's like gab is the
i mean tr at least like
when trump makes a post on true social
against 10 000 likes you know what i
mean like nobody yeah okay maybe wait
can you find any post from parlor that
has even one like oh well let me just
get off of benny johnson's page and see
if somebody else loser
can't even get one [ __ ] like
love maybe you need to log in to see the
likes uh i guess it's possible here i'll
i'll join let's try yeah
let's go i just gotta know if it really
is let's girl likes should i watch
crowder doing his uh black impressions
like 10 seconds of it might be a little
too hot to handle
well trigger well i mean he's on youtube
so yeah he's uh no he's brilliant and
hilarious i don't know what you're
talking about this is the uh
the the um
comedic genius
stephen crowder
darling of the right president
you
i thought the lesson they would want to
do
wasn't that a big problem
isn't that why arsenio hall calls
himself the urban man's johnny carson i
think so yeah
wait let me go back a little bit oh yeah
he's talking about he's talking yeah
yeah black farmers he's talking about
he's like man they're just gonna go buy
crack you know what the irony is that
like no of course black people wanted to
be black people wanted to be farmers as
well but the original subsidies that
were offered to uh farmers in america of
course suspiciously never were offered
to black people they were historically
excluded from said subsidies that you
know gave a gigantic advantage to white
farmers well even going back to when
slavery was abolished they absolutely
[ __ ] over all of the yeah of course uh
they you know at that when when slavery
was abolished they had a really
good plan to give them all money and
land to get them started in life which
40 acres
and then yeah which and then they're
like nah no they did they did the
government actually did end up offering
uh
some form of of uh reparations just not
to black people
uh they offered it to the slave owners
for the uh slaves that they had freed
yeah the loss of uh loss of profits i do
wonder how different this country the
landscape would be okay for african
americans in this country if they got
those oh i've always been an advocate
for uh raising the south like if if the
if in the aftermath of the civil war if
the
if if sherman had gone further if like
they if if the american government the
federal government actually [ __ ] uh
uh like truly delivered a a strike like
a like a crushing blow and not simply
like embarrassed the south in the
southern uh aristocracy and actually
like killed more slave owners john brown
style
uh and and punish them for you know uh
uh trying to desperately cling on to
ownership of human beings
uh there would be a drastically
different uh reconstruction period which
would have been way more successful
except uh the republican party at the
time the liberals i guess or the more
progressive party at the time
um which did have some you know uh
socialist marxist uh leanings as well uh
basically uh caved to the cries of
uh the right-wing uh confederate
southern aristocrats which is awesome
because they literally just lost a war
yeah
yeah they they cry bullied their way out
of uh successful reconstruction
and and you know the kkk and all this
other stuff the more i learned about all
the law like institutional uh racism the
way that african americans got
absolutely [ __ ] over the more i'm in
favor of reparations i'm actually
totally in favor of reparations i'm a
big i'm a big-time reparations advocate
you know because it's easy to be like no
no how are we ever going to do that it
just doesn't make sense there's
different things but actually now that i
think about it more and learn about the
history i'm 100
reparations i deserve it it's fair and i
think that um
america ironically uh did this in the
aftermath of world war ii as well like
there were other methods of dealing with
the nazis nuremberg trials and and also
just like straight up you know throwing
them in a pile and [ __ ] executing
them um which was way more successful
and way better
uh but america of course uh you know
operation paperclip and and also the uh
involving germany and nato
utilized the nazis and fascists and
positions of power in all of europe as a
effective force against what they
perceived to be the real threat which
was communists the only militant group
that successfully ousted nazis in all of
these european countries and even
non-revolutionary reformist
uh social democrats and and trade
unionists as well
um and we did this exact same thing we
caved to again the reactionary uh slave
owners the reactionary slavers in the
reconstruction era historically speaking
what should have happened is is uh you
know the same treatment of the nuremberg
trials for a lot of the slavers
yeah i mean at the time there was
people had way too much
people just hated black people on the in
the north too you know despite the
fighting oh yeah and abraham lincoln i
think the whole thing was so sensitive
and uh
i understand you know
i understand the decision but yeah in
retrospect
uh we should have burned it all down
have you found a post with the i have
and i it was a good call it turns out
you do need to be logged in that they'll
be able to see interactions twenty
thousand take it back he didn't have
zero likes he had 20. 20.
this [ __ ] is popping yo the left is
seething
wait let me read the comments let me
read the comments i guess they probably
hide the interactions like that to not
let people know
how shitty the interactions are
but you'd think they would just write
like log in to see
right yeah because it just looks
pathetic and it is pathetic um lefties
can't mean i'm dead i laugh these are
fake comments i laugh too many times
uh this is gonna be the shittiest set of
memes i've ever seen my balls see better
things and all it sees are my boxers
uh benny let me send you some fresher
memes hit me up bro i'll help you smash
and slam your way to the top of the meme
pool yeah people are loving it this is
[ __ ] insane
that's uh this is great audience
retention is nuts anyway let's look at
crowder real fast located exclusively
for colored farmers of color farmers of
color by the way talking about react uh
you know a type of reparation they're
like uh let's let's make sure that farm
african american farmers
during this covid get the help they need
to keep their farms going and crap this
is crowder's reaction to that
as long ago as
1965 the u.s department of agriculture
discriminated against black farmers but
little was done to address 100 years ago
yeah [ __ ] you can't be that dumb of
course a hundred what happened 100 years
ago matters today yeah you think they
just [ __ ] and
invent money at a thin air my favorite
part about like it's like so stupid a
hundred years of inequality have gone by
and the government is finally like uh
springing into action and even then
stephen carter was like no oh it doesn't
except for 100 years yeah so
[ __ ] like clearly that's the
reason why it didn't happen in 1965
either because there was other stephen
crowders out there way more of them and
way more [ __ ] vocal if you're if
you're
in abject poverty and discriminated
against
it and bro i i don't need to explain
it's so obvious of course it matters 100
years later but here it gets worse guys
most happy about the new policy these
people so yeah
i'm going to plant that corn go get a
job but obama i'm the president i'll
plow in that air you
i thought the last thing they would want
to do is be farmers wasn't that a big
problem
yeah isn't that why our city paul calls
himself the urban man's johnny carson i
think so yeah
wow
that little piglet is a friend of his is
the absolute word dude it's like it's
like old school racism yeah
bands are so bad he's like yo why would
black people want to be farmers they
were slaves yeah [ __ ] got him you
know what bro you belong in a [ __ ] do
you eat out of a trough you little
piglet
yeah so like is your audience like a
bunch of [ __ ] like conservative
zoomers and [ __ ] for the most part no he
has to be he dude of course he's eating
out of a trough he's in a prison of his
own making dude he has to be [ __ ]
stephen crowder's like fall guy every
day
that's way worse though than anything
that's a that's a hell that you are
living every [ __ ] day of your life
when saint when when uh
uh when sam cedar joined the call piglet
there went running to master uh behind
oh yeah that was like my favorite dt he
gave him like piggy come on piggy come
on pig come run defense for me now yeah
so sad such a sad existence for that man
crowder's leprechaun yeah for sure do a
little jig
yes crowder
i just want to know who's watching
steven crowder's youtube channel that
understands an arsenio hall reference
right what the well he's not funny dan i
know but and like i think that even his
audience is not what about the
beaty-eyed f what did he call sam cedar
the eyed rav velveteen rabbit the
velveteen rabbit like we still don't
know what that means i don't think i
don't think stephen crowder's audience
is as young as you think it is i know
for a fact that i have the youngest
audience out of any like uh uh political
content creator on youtube across the
board like like
years younger nobody
is
no i i'm pretty sure his audience is
like it's probably like older it's if i
had to guess
uh
i would say 18 to 35. no no shot i don't
believe it's older than that i don't
know i think it's old people
oh people [ __ ] go on youtube too man
we're [ __ ] old
no i get it but like you're talking like
gen xers like people in their 40s and
50s are watching this crap
can you share your analytics
my chat like their their parents watch
ben shapiro and [ __ ] you know yeah ben
shapiro i can see but crowder is just
like he's his
whole thing is just so [ __ ] juvenile
that i would assume it's
now but like with only boomer references
right which is what baffles me when he's
talking about arsenio hall and [ __ ] but
yeah i mean maybe you're right maybe it
is a little bit older than i'm thinking
we need to see your analytics bro
all right let's just see what the [ __ ]
benny cooked up and then i don't know i
can't deal with this [ __ ] anymore
i'm getting i'm getting i'm seething and
crying my tears it's actually just bad
bro i don't know what to tell you
i mean dude yeah it's not even like the
room you know what i mean it's not so
bad it's good
it's just embarrassing it's just bad
exclusively on parlor [ __ ] you have 20
likes
the only place people watch it is
twitter isn't that [ __ ] awesome
[Music]
welcome to the left can't meme it's your
host benny johnson
the left cat name
[Applause]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] beautifully spicy this
week you just can't get any better than
this ladies and gentlemen if i were a
democrat
pr flack and if i were to try and
sabotage democrats right now what i
would do is i would take the term ultra
magga and the term king the mega king
and i would apply them
to donald trump and therefore ladies and
gentlemen it is with my great pleasure
that i bring to you the ultra backup
king meme episode oh hell yeah dude
let's go and of course donald trump
posting on truth social return of the
great maggot dude i love that he's so
[ __ ] hot
from lord of the rings and will the king
return will donald trump run in 2024 let
us know in the comments this makes me
happy this makes me so happy let us know
in the comments [ __ ] you have three
comments comments
here i'll go look let's see what they
let him know in the car dude this is so
sick i love this because like
they're such servile little piggies dude
they love this they're like ah monarchy
reinstitute we should have a monarchy
like the same people who are like yeah
we [ __ ] you know we did the we did
the the tea party and like you know we
we defeated the the monarchy like [ __ ]
you or like literally please please
i love i love sucking boots so hard and
who made this the greatest boot would be
the royal one this is great cam you just
drew this
i traced over you wow that's the
thumbnail photo
that's exactly
how i feel
despair
yeah i wish i was a surf man i wish i
was an indentured servant i'd be sick
yeah
you're you're getting the conservative
alpha mindset uh embedded in you right
now as we speak yeah i want trump to bet
my fiance on my wedding night yeah so
sick they actually i think a lot would
find that dope yeah no oh for sure would
you please take my wife remember
remember the women would like to grab my
[ __ ] please my lord shirt oh my god no
it's great yes my lord oh it would be
wonderful
you've honored me by soiling my wife and
first-born daughter
so great sir grab grab my [ __ ] please
old dramaga
the great murgo king yes winnie the pooh
donald trump as a kid hold on do you see
how he explains that joke real fast
he goes
the great murgo king
yes winnie the pooh winnie the pooh poop
[Music]
okay
what that's great he goes he's right
is it not winnie the pooh it is sorry it
is winnie the pooh
all facts winnie the pooh
tie it all up there
that's called a punch line or something
the great manga king drama winnie the
pooh he's the great
king yes great winnie the pooh
wendy the pooh
dude oh this is like
yeah dude
all the old people watching gonna die
from laughter they're laughing too hard
at this you're gonna [ __ ] have heart
attacks yeah let's come on we gotta
preserve the the voter base yeah
um here is donald trump looking in a
mirror and having delusions of grandeur
and this is awesome meme
i had to beat off
uh i will i will fight back against that
he does look he does look like that all
the time and he is very sexy and he's a
king in his own right okay
anyway that's enough of this [ __ ] guy
that's my thick king what were the call
bits about if if uh
i'm trying to find that because that's
episode three right is this soy face
is this like let's before we leave i do
wanna i do wanna end on a high note and
show you benny johnson's brilliant take
which was also on the rundown as well
uh
now benny when he's not actually
crafting the most uh delectable
delightful
memes for his show
very much
what is betty doing he's taking on
liberals and owning them on a different
platform you have it you can pull it up
twitter
um are you pulling [ __ ] up i am not
pulling it up it's on the rundown
our boy benny is back where do i
thinking of it is it here i mean i can
pull it up you can't pull it up yeah
pull it up here boom there you go i'm
trying out my wait you can put it on
here so i can see yeah no you'll be able
to i just did i just pulled it up oh and
put it on the other side oh so so i have
a boom oh okay there you go you got the
technology well that's the first time
you ever pulled anything up yeah i
pulled that [ __ ] up jamie yeah this is
this honestly this tweet is part of the
reason why i'm black build again because
it's so mind-numbingly dumb you
shouldn't be allowed to be this dumb and
there's no way he actually believes that
i mean it's just it's i don't know no i
think he does i think he's that stupid
and i think like it doesn't matter
because the audience is that stupid so
like they can get away with whatever the
[ __ ] they want just like no yesterday's
lauren bobert take about like uh you
know after 9 11 we didn't ban planes uh
can be repeated by steven [ __ ]
scalise which is like the third most
powerful republican in congress
currently you know what i mean like
that's how
that's they're they're serving their
audience and here's benny j hold up read
it read it here's benny johnson saying
uh matthew mcconaughey more gun control
now also matthew mcconaughey
shooting guns in movies
incredible take
i mean dude he's he's killing it he's
right uh you [ __ ] owned get [ __ ]
wrecked liberals absolutely
bro i just it's like it's a movie dude
it's it's not really who he is yeah
that's no it's it's
it's it's a movie right like that's not
he's not those characters in real life
right no i know matthew mcconaughey uh
claims to [ __ ] hate uh killing people
and yet he has killed people in movies
uh but do you know how movies wait wait
wait wait wait benny you know how movies
work right no those don't those aren't
actually things playing out no he thinks
he thinks he's real
yeah somehow
okay
the other part of this is like obviously
idiotic is is like i am a fan of
shooting guns i like shooting guns i've
talked about this many times i've shot
guns on stream uh responsibly
and uh you can be a gun owner not saying
that i am or or not i'm not gonna you
know release that information but
uh you can enjoy shooting guns and also
still uh push for adequate gun safety
gun regulation yes i'm a gun character
references mental uh health evaluation
to ensure that part of responsible gun
ownership i'm a gun owner i want all
those things but in benny's world it's
like if you've played in a movie where
you're [ __ ] firing weapons like you
you're hypocritical for saying what the
[ __ ] that's just it's like bro what are
you doing yeah the amount of regulation
necessary for even firing blanks in a
[ __ ] movie set unless your alec
baldwin is also profoundly higher than
like being able to purchase a weapon at
the age of 18
right before you [ __ ] shoot up a
school
um
it's just it's it's hard to and that by
the way
i saw some faze guys who are like
conservative [ __ ] bags or some other
like gamers who are conservatives who
are like yo this is crazy and true i was
like [ __ ] you play video games they're
violent do you think violent video games
because i'm sure
there's all these you know there's like
these guys that we're saying yeah let me
look at lovely i'm gonna call him out
cause i thought it was so dumb i wanted
to [ __ ] [ __ ] no way yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hold up face up yeah i [ __ ] i phase
up i'm never phasing down so like i'm
actually i'm actually quite shocked
brother banks would never allow this to
happen
brother banks has lost control of his
org yeah what the [ __ ] going on
he's still worried about nfl
rug pulls okay
you know that guy
yeah no myth is mine wait wait wait wait
wait wait
myth is the one i'm
yeah myth no no no that's the son of a
bee's boy yeah yeah
yeah that's my homie that
that has related probably being
sarcastic
yeah that's my cousin that's your cousin
yeah he's my cousin yeah
myth is the homie
he is uh he also loves uh
he's very good but he would never have
it
up ethan hold the [ __ ] i have his mom's
number if you want to speak to her oh i
misunderstood okay wait let me just yeah
let's call his mom yo that's dearborn's
finest dude
how dare you okay okay you know what
i totally missed what did he say that
you thought was uh uh was serious okay
so first i saw what is this what are you
pulling up well he he mentioned that uh
about the violent video game thing i saw
this i called i called
i called kyle written how's the dork ass
loser
and then he did a thumbs up
and i was like okay wait who myth did
yeah to you yeah he was like i know he
could have gone laying around he was
just playing around i clicked his
profile
and then i went to the
he quote tweeted benny's matthew
mcconaughey what did he say and he said
bro what lol and and at first i thought
he was
not oh he's dunking on him
no no no no no no no no no
no smith is the homie yes he's not shut
up myth
we love you that's your cousin yes and
his brother likes the show also he
doesn't follow me so i thought he was
just a conservative troll damn dude
ethan come on bro not not everyone that
doesn't follow his wow
bro it was all
sorry myth i'm following you
and i'm just going to tweet him right
now i'm just going to tweet him sorry
yeah i pulled this up to back up the
point that i thought you were making
ethan but now that we've shamed you one
yeah we can just shame on you how dare
you wait there uh i i wish there was i
wish they were [ __ ] uh like an actual
[ __ ] cousin
[Laughter]
like first cousin no not first cousin
yeah his grandmother signed for my whole
family to come over from lebanon oh wow
so you know your life tim
yeah i didn't grow up with him i'm older
than him but yeah and he's like one of
my very good friends like we had you
know we had christmas dinner in my house
with my family and she's just stupid at
me
you know there's a lot of trolls so i
thought it was like that's what happens
bro you you don't don't let the brain
rock get to you you know it's one of the
hardest i didn't say anything i just
thought
pro gamer right really good gamer yeah
he is
i think also a very
family members is like a professional
shooter too right yeah one of his older
brothers yeah one of his older brothers
is a competitive shooter he is like
he's a freak like when we went
uh i i have a youtube video like when we
went on when we went to the gun range
together he literally almost out of
nowhere he never shot a gun before out
of nowhere almost out shot the [ __ ]
like trainer that we were working with
he like set up a little course for us
and his time was remarkably close to the
[ __ ] time of the trainer wow he was
wild he's a gamer
yeah yeah he's an american he's a he's a
renaissance man he's funny he's handsome
he is incredible yeah he's a king yeah
all right shout out yes we love you the
young architect
yeah that's what this is called he broke
fortnite you can get mad at him for that
he's the reason why fortnite is like
unplayable if you're like over the edge
though 14 there you have it the man the
myth the legend
shout the [ __ ] out all right uh it is uh
12 30. i think we gotta wrap it up
you gotta go yeah i gotta go i i i'm not
even streaming today i'm just doing a uh
austin
price is right
show you guys are big on the shows on
twitter yeah there's like a lot of
everyone's trying to do shows
i'm not i'm not a big show guy i like
just doing my own thing you know right
i'm too parasocial i need to like talk
to my chat every day well we had fun
didn't we
yes
jordan jordan
listen
do we have some parting words for jordan
i think you got to just lighten up and
open your mind a little bit to the
possibility
that people have different let me finish
that people have different sec like
attractive preferences
than you do man
[ __ ] you
oh dude come on jordan
seriously aren't you a phd a
psychologist how dare you [ __ ] you if
you don't like it he's doing it again
this is just the man's office
no no
all right
and that's that
are you planning on eating meat anything
other than meat yes yeah okay good good
that's good at least he's like you know
balancing it out i hope it's not apple
cider jordan so don't pull any moral
stunts on me because you're irritated
about my opinion
well it's just it's just apple cider
[ __ ] you okay all right he's we can't
get through to him and [ __ ] you if you
don't like it all right all right i
can't get through this really i gotta i
gotta give the man credit that's that's
a strong [ __ ] you and yes [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you is there any does
hassan have a chance with your daughter
because we have maybe there's a
possibility of that connection yes
oh
okay good okay great would you go all
meet for michaela absolutely not
no oh it had the appearance of a thick
mat of hair oh god no jordan don't do it
that is unacceptable and i will king
shame him for that i'm going to be
honest are you cool if michaela if the
all meat diet made maquila's pubes run
to her knees i no i i don't i don't i
don't want to think about any of that i
don't want to i just don't want to think
about the all me diet is like so gross
you think your [ __ ] smells like uh okay
okay let's not i don't want to [ __ ] you
her [ __ ] smells
shout out myth ladies and gentlemen who
we love
and [ __ ] benny johnson who's an unfunny
loser it's true [ __ ] you
and shout out jordan peterson who needs
to chill he needs to get back on the
benzos yeah or or
eat something other than me yeah all
right guys see you next week on friday
tomorrow everyone else
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you